[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN WALSH: Hi,
thanks everybody.
I really appreciate
you having me
here, and taking your
time out of your day
to come listen to me.
I'm going to read some things,
and talk, and play some clips.
We can do Q&A at
the end, but if you
have any questions in the
middle, just spit them out.
Because conversation is
more interesting than
like a monologue to me.
OK, so basically the
short story of this
is I was like 22, very sad,
lonely, heartbroken dude,
as many people in their
young 20s find themselves,
and also buying way
too many records, CDs.
And I just came upon
"Astral Weeks" in a store
in Newton, a Newbury
Comics in Newton.
And the title and
the front cover--
I was like, I got to see
what kind of music that is.
And I ended up--
long story short-- becoming
obsessed with the record.
And I don't know how
familiar you all are with it,
but on the back there's
this poem that's
signed by Van Morrison.
And he's talking about like
Hyannis and Cambridge Port.
And just being a bad geography
student, I was like, well,
those must be places
in Ireland as well.
And it took me a while to figure
out he was talking about here.
And then when I did confirm
that, I was like, well,
why the hell was he here?
That makes no sense,
he's from Belfast.
And it turns out he had a
terrible record deal with Bang
Records out of New York City.
And they were
mobbed up, and there
was a guy put in charge of Van
that was basically a mobster.
And I visited him
at his apartment.
And that's where we'll
start, if I can find it.
"Now that Berns was dead,
Morrison's main contact
at Bang Records was Carmine
"Wassel" de Noia, whose father
was the inspiration for
the character Nicely-Nicely
in "Guys and Dolls."
Wassel was an even less
forgiving boss than Berns.
While the FBI classified him
as only a low level mobster,
he was still a scary menace.
In 1975, Wassel was
convicted of payola,
bribing radio DJ's in exchange
for heavy rotation of a record,
which might not
sound like rough work
until you hear how Wassel
described a typical day.
"So here's this disk
jockey," Wassel said in 2001.
"I threw him up at the window,
pick him up, flip him, shake
him by the ankles, ninth floor.
All the change fell
out of his pockets.
Some friends of
mine picked it up."
Even today, Wassel hasn't lost
any of his tough guy schtick.
When I ring him up one night, he
answers, "hello, city morgue."
He's lived for
more than 50 years
on West 72nd Street
in Manhattan.
When I arrive, he's wearing
a loose white undershirt,
blue pajama pants, and
thick-rimmed black glasses.
He's friendly, forthcoming,
and a little scattered.
"I helped that guy out,"
Wassel insists about Morrison.
"If he ever sees me again, he
better stand up and salute me."
It was weird, he didn't realize
anything he had done was bad.
Like when he told me that
at a party for the release
of "Brown-Eyed Girl," he
threw Tiny Tim off a boat
into the Hudson River.
He was laughing, he was
like, "he was all wet."
And then his nurse was there,
and she was laughing too.
I was like, has he badly
influenced this woman?
That seems like a terrible
thing to do to another person.
Wassel says he got Bert Berns
started in the music business.
Of course, Berns had been
involved in the music business
long before they met.
So what he actually meant
was that he introduced Berns
to full-blown gangsters like
the Genovese family member Patsy
Pagano, and to the quick
results that brute force yielded
when applied to the
creative industries.
Back in Berns's day,
this included everything
for bullying performers back
into studios, dismantling
local record bootlegging
operations with a sledgehammer,
and finding a way
to borrow money that
didn't require a credit check.
These connections gave
Berns and Bang Records
an advantage that
could level the playing
field against the more
established labels.
In August, 1967, Berns organized
a belated record release party
for "Brown-Eyed Girl" on a boat
that departed from 50th Street
in Manhattan.
Van attended with his
new love, Janet Rigsbee.
There's a picture
from this evening
hanging on Wassel's wall.
The framed photo shows the
singer sporting a rare smile.
Janet looks happily taken
back by the fanfare.
Berns is glancing at Janet.
And Wassel is in back, a giant
cigar stuffed in his mouth,
with his eyes closed
and head tilted back.
Performer Tin Tim tried to join
the festivities that night, I
learned, but Wassel says
he threw him overboard
into the Hudson River.
"They had to fish him out
of there," Wassel tells me.
"He was soaked."
At some point in the
evening, Morrison
delivered a soulful
set for the revelers.
I asked Wassel to tell
me more about what
happened with Van Morrison
right before the singer fled
New York.
For a moment, he looked stumped.
"Oh," Wassel remembers, "I
broke his guitar on his head."
This is true, here's
what happened.
One night, Wassel visited the
singer at the King Edward Hotel
where Morrison and
Janet were staying.
They were already anxious.
Morrison's immigration peppers
were not wholly in order,
and he was worried
about being deported.
His last visit to
an office trying
to correct the work
permit issue ended
with an official telling him,
you're now deported, bye-bye.
During the encounter
with Wassel,
Morrison was
severely intoxicated.
Wassel asked about a radio
he'd given Morrison which
now appeared to be broken.
Morrison's temper flared
up, worsened by booze,
so Wassel put an end
to his incomprehensible
string of expletives by
smashing the singer's
acoustic over his head.
Morrison would later tell
others that he and Janet once
returned from dinner to find
their hotel door full of bullet
holes.
Neil Diamond, Berns's
other poised-to-make-it act
at the time, reported
similar calamities.
The unholy hell that was
unleashed upon Van when
Bert died was really
horrible, Janet
recalls, noting
another instance where
Wassel banged on
the door, screaming,
"you're finished in the music
business, do you hear me?"
All of this may
have had something
to do with why, in early 1968,
Van Morrison and Janet Rigsbee
hastily got married and moved
to Cambridge, Massachusetts."
So that kind of sets up the
whole story of the book here
is--
in all the Van
Morrison biographies,
his time in Cambridge is like
a page, half page, two pages.
And what I've found when I found
people who were in his band
or who saw him,
there were plenty
of stories, and all this
important structural groundwork
for "Astral Weeks"
being laid here.
His Boston band was called
the Van Morrison Controversy
for some reason.
It's the only time he's
tacked on a band name.
And there were three
distinct lineups of that.
And if the musicians
were alive and someone
remembered their name, I
was able to talk to them.
And it's just kind of like
a real comedy of errors.
We think of him as a
legendary singer now,
but he was kind of
eating dirt all summer.
Like outside of one show, after
they performed "Brown-Eyed
Girl," somebody walked
up to him and said,
did you write that
song "Brown-Eyed Girl?"
And he said, yeah.
And then he said,
the Rolling Stones
have really gone downhill.
[LAUGHTER]
And Van asks John Sheldon, his
guitarist, what that meant.
And he was like, ah,
just forget about it.
[LAUGHTER]
But when it came time to
turn this story into a book,
me and Ed Park, my
editor at Penguin,
decided that it would be
more interesting to kind
of use Boston and the
year of '68 as an anchor
and tell these other stories
as a way of fleshing out
the context of where
the album came from.
And what we found
was oftentimes,
when I would find
another exciting story,
they would have a Van
Morrison anecdote.
So next thing I'll do is
read from a chapter called
"The Silver Age of Television."
And it's about this
really bizarre show
that was on WGBH for two
years for some reason.
So this is from far after
I found David Silver,
and before any of
this was online,
you could only kind of
go to GBH's archives
or meet with David Silver
to watch these episodes.
"Only about 20 minutes of
scattered clips exist online.
David Silver has agreed to show
me a full of the few episodes.
God knows what this
is, he says, softly
squinting as he scrolls through
a video player on a laptop.
This was just craziness.
The show is about to begin.
It goes like this--
a swarm of inkblots
cut to a circular logo
bouncing across the screen.
A child announces the title of
the show, then looks confused.
A Jim Kweskin song plays
as the inkblots return.
A half-second clip
of a woman in a red
dress staring off
into the distance.
Edits happen without warning and
truncate sentences throughout.
Host David Silver
sits on the floor
and asks the woman a question,
but her answer goes unheard.
Cut to stock footage
of a man talking
about producing high
school yearbooks.
Cut back to the
woman telling Silver
about an impending
cataclysmic event.
Micro cuts to old commercials.
Aretha Franklin's
"Respect" starts to play.
Behind Silver and the
lady in the red dress,
a dozen young
people dance wildly.
Seated to their left and
right are extremely old
man and woman watching.
Backward sequence of
Silver eating a banana.
Stock footage run through
an effects module,
rendering it in a new array
of psychedelic color patterns.
Black and white footage
of samurais fighting.
The editing pace quickens.
Four distinct audio
tracks play at once, often
at odds with another.
Silver, in all black,
fences with a woman
dressed all in white.
Inkblots overlay the duel.
A woozy pattern spins as we
hear news reports of the Vietnam
War.
"You can be frozen for
several hundred years,"
a woman in a
floral-patterned dress
tell Silver, while the dancers
clap in time behind them.
"That would break up the
monotony of eternity."
The elderly pair looks confused.
Dave Wilson, an "Avatar"
newspaper founder,
drives his motorcycle
onto the set,
and does loops around the whole
scene, the exhaust thickening.
"Mustang Sally" by
Wilson Pickett plays.
Silver lies down with
the woman on the floor.
The dancers keep
swaying, and Wilson
continues to circle
everything with his hog.
With no fanfare, the
end credits appear.
The sound fades out.
You're left in total silence,
watching the elderly pair's
reactions.
They do not understand
what just happened, do you?
The episode, titled
"Madness and Intuition"
won a National Education
Television Award."
So as entertaining as I
find "Antiques Roadshow,"
this sounds a little stranger
of what public television can
allow on the air.
So basically, this
story is about how
David Silver and the show
became very famous in Boston
and Cambridge very briefly, and
then got in a lot of trouble.
So they aired this--
Howard Zinn of course,
quite famous author,
but was just a BU
professor at the time.
And so he just goes on this like
three minute anti-Vietnam war
rant, which was like the
second punch for the show.
After this clip, "thank you,
Professor Zinn," Silveer says.
"I agree with every
word you said."
But the mood inside
WGBH was grim.
The program director,
Michael Rice,
told director Fred Barzyk
that what they'd done
was unacceptable.
"We're embarrassed," he said.
"This may be the
end of the show."
Barzyk feigned mild concern.
The two colleagues had a
love-hate relationship,
and Barzyk knew how to
push Rice's buttons.
Now he wondered how to respond.
"This is an experimental
show, and you can't win
if you don't lose," he cajoled.
"You have to have disaster so
you can do something better."
Rice called his bluff.
He proposed having their
sit down conversation
about the appropriateness
of that show's
content on the air as
a live new episode,
maybe the finale of the series.
"Let's do that," Barzyk
said, his eyes lighting up."
So what they did was
put the show on trial,
and it's an episode of the show.
So basically, they do
this elaborate dance,
purposely misunderstanding
his question,
till they're finally
like, why did you
talk about Nancy Sinatra's fake
breasts on public television?
"Silver suggests the idea
of ending future shows
with a note about his opinions
not reflecting the station's
beliefs, to which Rice
replies, "the issue is
whether we want anything to do
with you in the first place."
The issue of Howard Zinn's
brutal anti-Vietnam editorial
is an afterthought, addressed
near the end of the debate.
Smith believes it should have
been followed by an opposing
opinion, while Rice calls
it an eloquent presentation
of a point of view.
Then Rice sums up, "whether
he likes it or not,
David Silver is now
a public persona.
Silver," he contends,
"has commandeered
WGBH for trivial purposes."
"I think that's a melodramatic
way of looking at it,"
Silver protests.
"I think it's significant that
we should end this discussion
on what is basically a
point of disagreement,"
Spergel concludes.
"Thank you for being with us."
I asked Barzyk if having
his professional credentials
questioned by his supervisor on
television was awkward for him.
"No, to me it was the height
of the entire series," he says.
"All drama is conflict,
the episode was theater."
In fact, Fred told me
that anytime Rice spoke,
he was in cahoots
with the cameraman
to close up on his
face or Silver's face,
and they would just
project the look
of someone being censored
as another kind of way
to cheat the trial here.
So letters in support
of the show flooded
in after this episode, and the
show got to remain on the air.
But not for long, which is
the rest of that chapter.
So one afternoon, Morrison just
showed up at Silver's house.
And Silver was one
of the few people
who knew his old band,
Them, in Boston at the time.
And the same manager was kind
of courting both of them,
and they just had
this afternoon.
Any story I found interesting
that was Boston in '68,
I earmarked to be in the book.
But if it also intersected
with Van Morrison,
the it kind of shot straight
to the top of the list.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RYAN WALSH: He's from
England, Manchester.
So he came over as a
visiting Tufts professor.
And there's multiple stories.
He remembers someone
suggesting that he
should try out for a TV show.
And his girlfriend
remembers that they
walked in off the street, and
said, he deserves a TV show.
[LAUGHTER]
So I don't know
which one is true.
AUDIENCE: Do you know if he had
a TV show there in Manchester?
RYAN WALSH: He didn't, no.
He was he was pretty young.
He had just-- he was a
hardcore Shakespeare scholar
back in Manchester.
So I mean, after
this show, he went on
to direct a documentary
about the Beatles, one
of the first documentaries
about the Beatles.
And he's been in
the record industry.
When I found him to
talk to him for this,
he was co-hosting a
mindfulness podcast.
And he was a great guy.
Both Fred and Silver, I
just loved talking to them,
and learning about
this crazy show.
I wish GBH would take a weird
chance like that today and air
something like this.
The next thing I'm going to
read and show you clips from
are about a problem we all
know, which is the hippie.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a chapter about an
underground newspaper called
"Avatar" in '67-'68 in Boston.
And it was kind of
a scandalous paper.
It published a lot of filthy
poems and words and pictures.
And this is about the censorship
efforts of Cambridge and Boston
officials to shut
the paper down.
"It started in Cambridge.
Throughout the first
10 months of 1967,
Mayor Daniel J. Hayes Jr.
had grown increasingly fed
up with a scourge
that was spreading
along the banks of
the Charles River,
and alarmingly, into the main
streets of his great city.
The problem?
Hippies.
"The great unwashed are creating
an intolerable situation
in our city by the
widespread use of drugs
and other anti-social practices,
such as boys and girls living
together under the
guise of free love
and without any benefit of
clergy," Hayes declared.
Two days after his announcement
of a war on hippies,
there was a
televised police raid
of 183 Columbia Street, a
house in a slum of Cambridge,
yielding narcotics arrests
for the 17 people inside.
"I never saw such
a filthy situation.
There are terms in
which I could use,
but I would not use
in public," the mayor
told reporters, proud
of his self-censorship.
Hayes was up for re-election
in less than a month,
and the purge was a way
of grabbing headlines.
One bizarre profile in
the "Harvard Crimson"
featured Hayes gleefully
sipping a chocolate shake,
smoking Newports, and
expounding on his hot new term
for hippies.
"It's not the hippie,
it's the hipbo."
Come again?
Hipbo comes from three
things, first hobo, second,
the combination of hippie and
bum, third from Lifebuoy soap.
Remember that commercial
with the fog horn blowing?
BO, BO.
That term did not catch on.
[LAUGHTER]
Hayes had no idea that Lyman,
the mastermind behind "Avatar"
hated the very concept of
the hippie just as he did.
But it wouldn't have mattered,
he knew filth when he saw it.
At first Hayes figured he could
shut the underground rag down
on a technicality.
The editors were warned
that their offices would
be condemned unless
they installed
a separate bathroom
for men and women,
"Boston Magazine" reported.
Rather than bow
to what they felt
was patent harassment, the paper
moved itself to 37 Rutledge
Street in Boston's South End.
The next issue of "Avatar"
featured a mock obituary
of Mayor Hayes.
At the mayor's behest, an
anonymous city council member
spread word to three of
Cambridge's biggest newspaper
stands that continued
sales of "Avatar"
would result in prosecution.
All capitulated.
Mel Lyman retaliated by
sending hordes of Hill people
into Harvard Square
to hawk the newspaper
the old-fashioned way."
So kind of the team
behind "Avatar"
were this communal
group up on Fort Hill
in Roxbury, led by this
harmonica banjo player named
Mel Lyman, who right around
the time the paper started,
started telling
everyone he was God.
And then things get
really weird up there.
And then half the
"Avatar" newspaper
is like you know just kind of
like an altar laid out for Mel.
So the "Boston Globe"
and local TV news
were obsessed with Mel and
the Fort Hill community,
and like just what
was happening up there
and how they were living.
At one point, the Lyman
family owned every house
on Ford Ave Terrace, and
even a couple on Ford Avenue,
forming an L-shaped territory
hugging the southwest corner
of Highland Park in Roxbury.
Though the constituent
standpipe belonged to the City
of Boston--" there's this--
you might have seen
it around town,
the giant tower you can see
from a lot of locales in Boston
up there in Roxbury.
"It belonged to the city, but
the Lymans cut the lock off it,
replaced it with
their own, and began
to fix up the
spooky-looking relic as well
as the weedy broken
glass-covered park that
surrounded it.
Throughout '67
and '68, Mel Lyman
in the Fort Hill
community were treated
as a curiosity in the press,
with reporters and TV producers
trudging up the hill to capture
a human interest piece in step
with the times.
But after Charles
Manson and his family
went on their killing spree
in Los Angeles in 1969,
the public regarded the
idea of communal living
under the direction of
a charismatic leader
with greater alarm.
David Felton, the editor of
Hunter S. Thompson's "Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas,"
had covered the Manson story
for "Rolling Stone,"
and in '71, he
went to Boston to investigate
the Lymans for the magazine.
His story spanned two
back to back issues,
and landed Mel on the cover.
The article identifies
many family members
by full name, investigates
Lyman's media company, titled
United Illuminating
Incorporated,
and interviews
devotees and defectors.
It's filled with
larger than life
details and startling quotes,
such as this one from folk
musician, Jim Kweskin, the
man who five years earlier was
famous for making music
with kazoos and washboards.
"The Manson family
preached peace and love
and went around killing people.
We don't preach peace
and love, and we
haven't killed anyone yet."
[LAUGHTER]
In the spring of 1968, Lyman
had a dream whose imagery
he felt was prescriptive.
The next day, he
ordered his followers
to construct a formidable
protective wall
around his house.
Like Van Morrison across
the Charles River,
Lyman was now commanding
people based on what
he saw when he was sleeping.
Now, driving down
Ford Ave Terrace,
the wall was the only
thing I could focus on.
As I got close to the door
they built into the wall,
I noticed a green mailbox
affixed to the structure.
On a piece of paper
taped to the mailbox
was a list of current
residents, Jim Kweskin,
United Illuminating, and
half a dozen other names
associated with
the Lyman family.
I looked up in shock at
the house behind the wall,
and saw the silhouettes
of some people
through the main bay window.
Mel Lyman has been gone since
1978, but in that moment,
I realized that his
family was alive and well,
and were still living
up on Fort Hill."
So that kind of launched me
into the book's other main story
thread, which is that community,
and what happened to Mel Lyman,
because they
wouldn't tell anybody
where or how he died in '78.
And basically,
they haven't talked
to journalists in decades.
But as I started just
e-mailing, poking around,
they reached out to me.
And then suddenly, they
were talking to me,
and I even took a
tour of the houses.
And yeah, so their story--
like Ian said there,
they started out
as kind of a community
based on let's create
a lot of beautiful music,
and where they ended up
was really far afield from that.
I'm going to just
read one more thing,
and then hopefully, we can
chat, and do some questions.
And thanks again for coming
and listening to this.
There's a later chapter in
the book about a James Brown
concert in the wake of MLK's
assassination, which is
a really famous story, concert.
Basically, the city
of Boston realized
they were damned
if they do, damned
if they don't in regards
to putting the concert on.
Because any major
city in America
right after that
assassination was on the cusp
of riots and unrest.
So what ended up happening
was that Mayor Kevin White had
to figure out what to
do about this concert.
And this section is a
short little history
about the history--
rock and roll has had a very
troubled past in Boston.
And this is the history
of it's banning,
and all the twists and turns.
"It started in the
spring of 1956.
At a rock and roll
dance at MIT, a student
was badly injured,
leading police
to shut down a similar event
the next week in Roxbury.
When Chuck Berry and Jerry Lee
Lewis hit Boston in May, 1958,
chaos erupted in the
streets after the show,
when a group of 25 boys
in identical satin jackets
got rowdy.
Papers claim that the
law-abiding youth suddenly
became bedeviled into
gangsterism and ran berserk.
A sailor was stabbed, dozens
of others were beaten.
The district attorney prosecuted
show promoter Alan Freed
under anti-anarchy
laws, declaring
he had unleashed a form of rock
and roll paganism in Boston.
Freed was eventually
released, but Mayor John Hynes
had seen enough, grumbling,
"these so-called musical
programs are a disgrace
and must be stopped.
As far as I'm concerned, Boston
has seen the last of them."
After Hynes left office in 1960,
the total ban on rock shows
was lifted, save for some at
the Boston Arena and the Boston
Garden.
City censor, Richard J.
Sinnot--" which is, by the way,
the greatest name
for a sensor, Sinnot.
And Boston still had a city
censor to the late '70s, which
was kind of unbelievable to me.
"But Sinnot was in
charge of figuring out
if an act was rock
and roll, or not
and they could be booked
at a place like that.
The Beatles were
allowed at the Garden,
for instance, because they
are not really rock and roll.
As for the Beach Boys,
Sinnot [? vacillated. ?]
"Some people have claimed
they're folksingers," he said.
Whoever decided that James Brown
was not rock and roll in 1968
had been woefully misinformed."
[LAUGHTER]
And you can watch the
entire James Brown concert
on YouTube, which I
can't recommend enough.
It's not only
historically fascinating,
but it's just one of the most
electric live performances.
So as you can see, Van Morrison
and Mel Lyman kind of snake
through the book.
But I tried to cover a lot of
ground, do a lot of history,
tell some fun stories.
And I hope you enjoy it
when and if you read it.
So thank you.
If anyone has any
questions or comments?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You've never
written a book before, right?
RYAN WALSH: That's right.
AUDIENCE: What's
the longest thing
you've ever written
before, and tell us
about making this transition
to being an author?
RYAN WALSH: OK.
Well, I went to BU for film.
And one of my majors
was screenwriting.
So probably the longest piece
I've written before this book
was some really terrible
screenplays in '01.
I think two full lengths, which
mercifully have gone missing.
[LAUGHTER]
And then for about
10 years after that,
it was nothing but songs.
I was just writing songs like
crazy, and I still do that.
And then it wasn't
until 2012 that I
started to do longer
pieces in "The Phoenix."
Yeah, but definitely the first
book, and I'd like to do more.
We'll see.
AUDIENCE: What was the
most compelling interesting
that you spoke with live?
RYAN WALSH: I mean, I talked
to a lot of interesting people.
I mean, one of the
biggest personalities--
in '68, it kind of
lays the foundation
for counterculture in
Boston that lasted just
until a few years ago.
Like this guy named Ray
Riepen, a Kansas lawyer,
he started BCN, the famous
rock station that just closed,
what, five years ago now?
He bankrolled the
"Cambridge Phoenix," which
became the "Boston Phoenix."
And he opened the
Boston Tea Party,
which was Boston's first
dedicated rock and roll venue.
And he was a smart guy
and a good businessman,
but he was not destined
to become like--
they called him the hippie
entrepreneur in "Boston Globe."
And he came into it by accident.
So like he doesn't have an
appreciation for the art,
but he's proud of what he did.
So like for instance,
I'm like Ray,
so the Velvet Underground
just stopped playing New York,
and they pretty much just
played the Boston Tea
Party for those few years.
I was like, did you
like that music?
And he was like, well, basically
they were a fucking joke.
[LAUGHTER]
They had a girl drummer.
And every junkie in
the New England area
would come out and see them play
"Heroin," which they obliged.
And just someone like-- even
at this point, when the Velvet
Underground are like
considered one of the best
bands of all time, Ray
is still trashing them,
even though they were one of
the biggest draws at his club.
And he was oftentimes,
mean to me.
Sometimes I'd ask a
clarifying question,
not because I didn't
understand, but I
wanted him to say it a
different way or something.
And he'd be like, I
just fucking told you.
How dumb do-- just really--
[LAUGHTER]
There were some people who
were hostile, basically.
But I knew I could do
anything for a year,
so I was like, I'll take any
bruises that putting this story
together comes with, you know?
AUDIENCE: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious,
I know you interviewed
a writer, Eric Kraft?
RYAN WALSH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Eric's got a book
called "When Do You Stop?"
I think it's "Where
Do You Stop?"
but I was just wondering if
you found it sort of difficult
as you were following
all these threads,
you mentioned that sort of
having a connection back
to Lyman or Morrison was sort
of one of your thresholds.
But if there were
moments when you
had to make tough calls about
whether a tangent kind of fit
in the fabric book or
not, and if maybe you
had any favorite bits that
didn't quite make it in?
RYAN WALSH: I had a
lot favorite bits.
I kind of went crazy and
turned in double the book.
And you really have to give
a tremendous amount of credit
to my editor, Ed Park.
Because not only
would it not exist
if it wasn't for him kind
of pushing me forward
with this idea, but he also
knew what was interesting.
I was like, no, this has to be
a Noah's Ark of information,
and I need to put
all of this in.
And he's like no, we'll just
put the good parts in, Ryan.
[LAUGHTER]
And at the end stage of editing,
it would be cut paragraph,
and then there used to
be a thoughtful note why.
And like in the 12th hour,
he would just be like, no,
or this sucks, or who cares?
was my favorite one.
But he was totally right.
I mean, there were interesting
tidbits that got cut,
but the heart of all
the stories remain,
and that's why I'm
so grateful to Ed.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I wanted you
to expand on a previous answer.
You had said you could
do anything for a year.
RYAN WALSH: Oh yeah.
AUDIENCE: My memory
is you've been
working on this a long time,
as long as I've known you.
RYAN WALSH: That's true, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I wondered how--
did you have an agent
from the beginning?
Or did you just believe in
this and shop it around?
I don't know if you
want to talk about that.
RYAN WALSH: Oh, sure.
I mean, you're
right, in a way, I
have been working on
it since like, 2014.
But it was in patches.
It was the article, and then
there was the book proposal.
Like the bulk of the real book
was a year, year and a half.
But you're right,
it did stretch on.
Basically, the process
of how this happened
was the article came out in
"Boston Magazine" about Van
on the run from the
mob here in Boston.
And people really
enjoyed that article,
passed it around a lot.
And I was headed up to Vermont
with the band to play a show.
We stopped for gas.
I checked my email,
and there was an email
from an editor at Penguin.
And he said, I know
a lot of editors
must be reaching
out to you, but I
used to have a column called
"Astral Weeks" about sci-fi.
Just talk to me first.
And I was like, oh yeah,
a lot of editors are--
just kind of fibbed about
that, which wasn't the case.
But didn't need
to do any of that,
because Ed was so enthusiastic,
and really ushered me
through the process.
He co-founded "The Believer"
magazine, if anyone knows that.
And he's a wonderful
novelist and editor,
and that's kind of
how it all happened.
AUDIENCE: Has
indirectly any word
come back Van Morrison's camp?
RYAN WALSH: No, not at all.
I mean, he really
stonewalled me.
I mean, at the end,
I was so desperate,
we did like a social
media campaign
where it like,
tweet Van Morrison
if you think he should talk
to me for like, five minutes.
I've talked to
every single living
person who played
on "Astral Weeks,"
or had something to do with
"Astral Weeks" except Van.
And all that accomplished
was annoying his social media
manager.
It's probably some 18-year-old
named Cory who's just like,
who the hell is this kid?
So no, no word
from Van Morrison.
Although "Rolling Stone"
wrote a very nice piece
about the book the other
day, and they pointed out
that the same week
the book came out,
Van just announced a new album.
And on that album is a cover
of a song from "Astral Weeks."
So if there's anything
that's the equivalent
of a sub-tweet on an album, that
could be interpreted as at FU
to me.
But I am not willing
to put that on record,
because it does make me
sound a little crazy.
AUDIENCE: Were there
topics that you've
tried to approach that
doors were closed?
Like, is there any
lines of questioning
you wish you would have
played out where someone was
like, no, we're not going there
RYAN WALL: Certain people
went off the record
about certain stories.
I mean, where it got hairy for
me was trying to figure out
why Mel Lyman, the leader
of the Fort Hill community--
what actually happened
to him, because there
was no death certificate.
They say he died in '78,
didn't tell anybody till '85,
and were just very
mysterious about it.
And I thought any time I
brought that up, it became
a cold awkward conversation.
Look, I don't enjoy putting
people in awkward positions,
but at the same time, it's a
pretty straightforward answer,
what happened to your
friend, you know?
AUDIENCE: '68 is a pivotal
year across the board
for the whole country
in many different ways.
Have you [INAUDIBLE] other 50
anniversary year books coming
out or things like that, are
you joined to the community
of people around that?
RYAN WALSH: I'm not,
not in any sense.
But when I was talking
about how long this took me,
we did know we wanted it
to come out early 2018.
Because certainly, by
the end of this year,
we're going to be exhausted
of looking at 50 years ago.
I joked with everybody
that by the time you're 30,
you've accidentally seen a dozen
documentaries about the '60s
without even trying.
But what I had noted was that
it's all Chicago, New York,
and San Francisco.
Those are the Beats,
fire-powered DNC, Warhol.
And then what's
happening in Boston?
So what I found was that
it was just as interesting,
perhaps not as glamorous,
definitely weirder.
So I hope people have a
little more fuel in the tank
to explore late '60s America.
AUDIENCE: You seem to
suggest that the year that
began around '68 in Boston
ended about five years ago.
RYAN WALSH: Right.
AUDIENCE: So what are you
alluding there [INAUDIBLE]??
RYAN WALSH: Well, I mean, the
simple closing of "The Phoenix"
and BCN are pretty
good indicators.
They had a 50-year run.
Those were the arms of
the Boston counterculture.
And "Boston Magazine"
ran an article last year,
does Boston have an
underground anymore?
Is there still a counterculture?
So people are asking
this question.
But yeah, I mean, it
was amazing to find--
like I said, my band
has performed on BCN
before it closed, shut down.
I got my start writing
in "The Phoenix."
To realize where the precise
beginning of all that
was a real honor to me.
But yeah, I do feel like--
without being dramatic--
it has come to a close.
I'm never a pessimist, like
ah, the old days were better.
Something probably
more interesting
is right around the corner.
AUDIENCE: Is there anything in
the book about the gun control
laws introduced in '68?
RYAN WALSH: The what?
AUDIENCE: Gun
control laws in '68?
Is there any reference to that
at all, any ties from the--
RYAN WALSH: There's not.
No, I actually didn't
know about that.
I knew things like, nationally
911 was introduced that year,
or the rating system that
they applied to movies.
But there's not much
gun play in the book,
except for three
of the community
members who eventually tried to
rob a bank in the early '70s.
And at the Boston Tea Party,
Little Richard apparently,
after he played a set, with
the audience still clapping
for an encore, he was
already backstage,
opened a glittering suitcase,
and deposited his gun
on the table, and just patiently
waited for his payment,
like as an indication,
you better pay me quick.
[LAUGHTER]
But no, what laws
were passed that year?
AUDIENCE: It was
[INAUDIBLE] that passed
the gun control measures.
The ones that
[INAUDIBLE] in context
[INAUDIBLE] I think it was.
RYAN WALSH: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
gun control laws history.
I remember the 1968 thing.
RYAN WALSH: OK, I'll
have to check it out.
Cool, anything else?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
[INAUDIBLE] planned?
RYAN WALSH: I have some ideas,
but we'll see what happens.
I mean, this just
came out a week ago.
So now I have to go promote
it, which is a joy for me.
Because I like talking about
stories and meeting folks.
So I would change it up.
I don't want to--
I love Boston, I've
always lived here,
but I do think I've
drenched everything
from what I want
to talk about here
from the city with this book.
So yeah, I hope you all like
it, and thanks for coming.
Have a great day at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN WALSH: I used Google
so much writing this book,
so thank you very much.